- On this episode I
go in The Startup Van.
(upbeat hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee show.
- Hey everybody, this is
Gary Vay-ner-chuk
this is episode 192
of the #AskGaryVee show.
Live from Dublin.
Dublin, Ireland
and The Startup Van.
DRock, we made it
to The Startup Van.
Gentlemen why don't you tell
everybody who you guys are
what The Startup Van is and
let's get into that show.
- Yeah of course.
Well, we started
The Startup Van.
- First tell them who you are.
- I'm Graham, this is Mark
and we founded
The Startup Van last July.
- You don't think Mark was
capable of introducing himself?
- I'm Mark, this is Graham.
- The whole
argument who goes first.
- Go ahead.
- Basically if you want to look
up GaryVee or you want to
look up Richard Branson there's
thousands of videos but there's
these great entrepreneurs in
early stage startups that their
videos are shit.
You look up a video and
it's bad quality,
bad sound, exterior noise.
- All the kind of stuff that I
loved doing for Wine Library TV,
shit production that
would drive DRock crazy.
But you guys wanted to create an
environment this cool van that
you could do
high-quality videos for them.
As a business, as a production
company where you would charge
them or as a platform to get
exposure and build our brand?
- Well we said we'd never
ever, ever charge the startups.
'Cause it isn't fair.
- But you'll charge other people
because you're bringing them
value and that's
going to bring exposure.
- Exactly.
- And imagine if you ever had
this Spotify founders or
Elon Musk or Zucks as original
thing all you need is one lotto
ticket and then you
build a real business.
- Exactly.
- See I figured out.
- Yeah. Exactly.
- Not even two minutes.
- That's the quickest ever.
- Guys, I'm a
business (censored) genius.
DRock when are they
going to understand?
- We thought we got it
but that's a record.
- How many have you done?
- About 250.
- Yeah.
- Wow. Good for you.
Wait a minute, when
did you start this?
- Last July.
- What, you do one every day?
- We do volume so we do
like 90 in one night.
- So we started at Web Summit.
We did about a hundred videos.
- I see. Got it.
You just sit here and have
people come in and
you bang them out.
- Exactly.
- How long are they?
- 'Bout two, three minutes.
Get in--
- It's a pitch?
- No, we didn't
just want a pitch.
No one's and 30, 40, 50 pitches.
- Right, a story,
a this, a that.
- And then we kinda throw 10
quick fire questions at them.
- So people have to learn
when they listen as well.
- Now you guys hustled
your way on to--
- Sorry DRock.
So sorry DRock.
- I appreciate the hustle.
DRock, I like to make jokes
about quality of content and
things of that nature but I'd be
lying if I didn't say that I was
affected when I took my little
one hundredth of a second.
I always get hacked.
There's 1 million people trying
to hack me right now to do
something in Helsinki and a
million people trying to hack me,
a 1 million?
There's tens if not hundreds of
people trying to hack me to do
something in Amsterdam,
in Mexico and now that my
GaryVaynerchuk.com, link that up
(bell dings), my tour is posted
people are trying to
figure out ways to get to me.
When I look for a second,
and that's what it was,
I said this looks cool.
This looks good.
And it was enough for
me to say let's do it.
- It worked, great.
That's what we wanted
to ask you when is
a hustle become annoying?
- It all depends on the person.
I'm very good.
Most of people don't piss me
off enough but some people the
second time you ask they're mad.
There's a lot of my
contemporaries, some of these
big names that we all know that
I know get super pissed,
super pissed.
- DRock's been super patient.
Crazy level of patience.
- Alright let's go.
There's big
arguments going on outside.
So let's get right
into the questions.
Vayner Nation we're going to
go rushed here, we're an alley,
people look like they want to
fight we're going to wrap it up.
Tell them five minutes,
five minutes
let's make it ten,
let's go. Boom.
- A question that I had--
- You guys get to play
the India role. This is
a big responsibility.
- Yeah, Irish India's.
- Irish India's, alright.
- Let's do it. Let's go.
Question number one.
Are these your
personal questions?
- Some yes.
- Cool.
- So the first on is when you
had to that conversation with
your dad that you were moving
with your own thing,
how did that conversation go?
- This is a good question.
The truth is this is
probably stunning
information for everybody.
We never really
fully had the talk.
We kinda had to talk three
years later believe it or not.
- Really?
- Really, which is contradiction
to so many things that
I've said to so many of you.
Communicate this that
and the other thing.
It was kind of a weird
way that we got into it.
Uh oh.
- [Policeman] Two minutes.
- [All] Ok.
- Two minutes we're fine.
- Why don't we stop
it here and move it?
Let's move it. Let's move it.
We're fine.
- Yeah. Cool. Cool.
- No reason to fight.
- No, were going ghetto.
Yeah, I like ghetto.
- So is it on to me now?
What did you just ask there?
- No, I'll finish it.
I'll finish it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So that was interesting.
We innuendoed to it.
My dad knew what was
going on but I was
straddling both things.
The book came out,
Crush It!, there was
a lot going on.
My dad wanted to get more
involved in the business and
there's no such thing as
two cooks in the kitchen.
If I give one to his
advice, even this.
Are you the two guys?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's not easy.
- [Mark and Graham] No.
- You guys are different dudes.
You got different perspectives.
You can be the best of friends,
best intentions,
love each other, everything.
VaynerMedia, I'm the CEO.
AJ is a COO.
I am one, he is two.
I was one running Wine Library
but it was causing friction
between my dad and I thought it
was an opportunity for me to try
other things and an opportunity
for my dad to be a one again.
With my management team Brandon,
Bobby, Justin, all those guys
Brandt at the time.
So it felt right and it worked.
My dad was happier.
My dad's an old school guy.
I over communicated with my
dad but some things like family
dynamics are tough
but it was great.
I don't know what episode
that it is with my dad.
- Sasha's cool.
- We're the best.
And we love each other.
And we love each other a lot.
Maybe we could have had an
official conversation,
we didn't.
That's the truth.
- Sometimes it's
easier that way.
- I don't recommend it.
It was far from my preference.
It was learned behavior over a
15 year period of time of
how we work together.
It was right for our, that's why
I'm so scared to give
advice all the time.
Every situation's different.
Work-life balance,
parenting, family business.
I give you my stories so I tell
the truth here now people are
like Gary over communicated
but there he didn't.
Trying to give the truth
but that's what happened.
- [Mark] We got another question
here as well what's the best
attitude to have if
someone mimics your idea?
- Great.
Tech meetup van.
You don't own this idea.
- No.
- Not at all.
- What are you the first two
(censored) dudes to--
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- There's been Taxi (censored)
Confessions, I mean come on.
- Yeah course.
- Be better.
- Yep. Yep.
- Get better guests, ask better
questions, execute better,
put up better micro-content.
Nobody gets to own
these ideas, guys.
- We were never worried.
People always say to us
what's to stop the Startup Tram?
- You're not going to win
because of The Startup Van.
It's a shtick.
It's a cool thing that's
(censored) cool,
I like it by the way.
But how you interview and who
you get and what you do with
that content is.
I'm not the first guy to
document my life and do a vlog.
I'm not the first guy in social.
It's never the first,
it's the best.
It's never the
first is the best.
- The best.
- Yeah, the best.
Do you know what I mean?
And guess what, you and
I don't get to decide
we're the best.
- Yeah, I know.
- They do. Got it?
- That't the thing.
- Yeah, yep.
- Since DailyVee came
out people can see,
and you said that's
why you did it,
people can see how
hard you work.
- Yes.
- Who's worth ethic do you
respect because
that's high praise
coming from you?
- My parents.
- Your parents?
- My parents
worked their faces off.
My mom never and have
a nanny, we didn't have
a babysitter ever.
She had three kids.
My mom did everything for us.
She regrets raising, I'm not
even capable doing my laundry.
I'm a slob.
My mom picked up
everything after me.
Things that she
liked to joke about.
That's what she wanted to do.
She did all the
work, no vacations.
We took no vacations.
Guys I took three,
three vacations in my life.
We worked all the time.
My dad worked every minute.
My parents it's learned
behavior by watching them
and probably my own DNA.
I respect my parents' work
ethic and I respect all the
single moms and
single dads out there.
You know life is complicated.
Been thinking a lot about as I'm
starting to build momentum as
somebody who's advice is being
taken seriously that I'm trying
to be very careful because I'm
starting feel a bigger
sense of responsibility.
- Yeah.
- I'm starting to get nervous
to be very frank with you.
Here giving advice and
tomorrow somebody's spouse
is going to die.
Die.
I had a distant
relative it hurts very bad.
He was diagnosed at 65 or
55 as you can tell distant.
Trying just to remember.
65 with cancer and
was gone a month.
Gone.
Now that kid, I know the kid
met him a couple times.
Met him at some family
functions his advice is
different now than
it was yesterday.
- It's just perspective.
- There's just all these
different variables, right?
Who I respect?
My parents because
I know that truth.
Who else do I respect?
Millions of people who work
really hard to provide because
life gave them a curveball.
You can do everything right
and your wife and kids can go
get killed tomorrow by a
truck falling over on them.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And so what?
You're gonna go
hustle the next day?
You're going to grieve.
You're gonna
adjust so I don't know.
I respect anybody who's
trying as hard as they can,
trying to live the
best life they can,
trying to do the right things
but no question my work ethic
only comes from two people and
I think you guys know this about
me I don't have any role models.
I don't care Richard Branson and
Steve Jobs and Mark Zuckerberg
and Albert Einstein and
Bill Gates none of these
people inspire me.
They just don't.
My parents do and then it
flipped into my responsibility
to my friends that worked for
me, my brother worked with me,
the DRock's of the world and
most importantly what's given me
unbelievable scale
is the community.
I get inspired by people
wanting to take selfies with me.
I get inspired with two guys who
are working their butt off in
Ireland who really
really wanted me on the show.
Because it would be good for
them to use my name to get other
guests and I like that.
- [Both] Yeah, yeah.
- I like that.
Or appreciated my work or
a percentage of both that.
Do you know what I mean?
- 100% yeah.
- There's a lot of ways
to get motivated outside.
I love that I motivate people
but I don't think we need the
big names at the top of the
heap to be the motivators.
- Yeah, that's we decided
as well with start ups.
We're going to look after every
startup that we can interview
from somebody who's
opened from five days ago
rather than two or three years.
- We got a guy at the end of
January who literally came into
van and he had quit his
full-time job that day.
- Yeah.
- And you could see the look
on his face was fear--
- Sure.
- but it was good.
- There is good fear.
- And we could sense.
- He knew what he wanted and
went out for it which is great.
- That's awesome.
- Great to see.
- [DRock] Let's do
one more question.
- Just one more question
on that, if you owned
The Startup Van and you were
to get one guest in, one guest,
who would you get in?
- Mark Zuckerberg.
- Mark Zuckerberg?
- The best
entrepreneur of this generation.
- Really?
- Sure.
That's instant boom.
- Mark, call us.
- That's instant, go get Mark.
Go see what that does for you.
- That's next.
- Well we're over in
the States soon enough.
- Good for you.
- We're in the States in July.
- You're going to take this?
- Not this. We're going to
get one over there.
- How they going to get this?
- It's like Air Force One.
Start Up Van.
- I get it.
- So we're going
over there in July.
It's going to be pretty cool.
- Cool.
- Thanks so much
getting in The Startup Van.
- Yeah.
- It's been amazing.
- It's been so cool.
- Guys, this is kind of
a unique #AskGaryVee.
I'm excited to do this
we had the kind of this,
DRock's kind of yelling at us.
Let's keep that part
where you yelled at us, DRock.
I don't know when DRock
all of a sudden became
the (censored) boss.
(laughter)
We should wrap it up
because we need to catch some
flights and I'm heading
over to London now.
Just had a great talk in
Dublin, really enjoying it.
Really enjoying the evolution
of the #AskGaryVee show.
Different flavors.
Obviously we'll get back to
our normal track but we had
some guests the other day.
Fun for you guys to join.
Good luck to you
on your ventures.
- Great.
- I really kind of did this, very
honestly, I liked their hustle
but what I like more
is I like you more.
I did this because of knowing
their model of interviewing
anybody here's what I'd like
to happen I assume you have a
website where people can just
apply to be a guest on the van,
right?
- Absolutely.
- And that is what?
- TheStartupVan.com
- Great. I want all of you that
have a startup to go
pound them and I expect them
to interview all of you guys
because of the nice
gesture I did that I'm passing
on to you guys.
Question of the day.
Word association,
I say Ireland you say?
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(fast paced hip hop music)